foreign
as we know the woke cultists among us
are constantly running a linguistic
inventory scanning through the catalog
of human language looking for random
words to suddenly out of nowhere and for
no intelligible reason declare
problematic and insensitive and this
week the cultists seem to be putting in
some overtime work as there are multiple
examples just from this week of benign
words and phrases being declared
suddenly and indiscernibly offensive but
today we're going to focus only on USA
Today and an article written by
diversity and inclusion reporter David
Oliver the headline asks is it time to
stop saying Aloha and other culturally
sensitive words out of context
not to spoil the ending but uh yes it is
time apparently that's that's what he
wants to tell us he writes quote Aloha
hola Shalom these are ways to say hello
in Hawaiian Spanish and Hebrew
respectively but just because you can
say something doesn't mean it's always
appropriate on the surface simple
greetings and phrases from other races
and cultures may seem fine to sprinkle
into our vernacular inclusive even but
did you know that Aloha doesn't just
mean Hello or goodbye
quote it's a greeting or a farewell but
the meaning is deeper says male Arvin
the director of Pacific island studies
at the University of Utah one of my
Hawaiian language teachers taught it to
me as aloha means recognizing yourself
in everyone and everything you meet if
you're not Hawaiian and you say it it
could come off as mockery and that's
just one word to think about the use of
certain words requires education
knowledge and a foresight to understand
when they should or shouldn't come out
of your mouth
yes David Oliver of USA Today will tell
you what should or shouldn't come out of
your mouth
you uh cannot be trusted to Simply go
around speaking and saying words all
willy-nilly you need guidance and
instruction and correction and David
Oliver is here to provide it very nice
of him
something to keep in mind by the way
when considering the subject that we
began the show with today people are
very squeamish about imposing our
Collective will on criminals punishing
them and forcing them to comply with the
law and the standards of basic human
decency but I'm willing to bet that uh
you know David Oliver himself would take
great exception to everything I said
about that subject and yet
these same squeamish gentle tolerant
folks suddenly adopt a quite different
attitude when it comes to normal
law-abiding citizens who say words and
express ideas that they don't like
now it's not true then to say that we
live in a permissive Society it's more
accurate to say that we are a society
permissive specifically of criminals and
social leeches but quite Stern and
controlling when it comes to normal
people who do say and think normal
things
now granted David isn't suggesting
caning or executing white people who use
the word Aloha but I'm not sure that he
necessarily objected that suggestion
either back to this article he says of
course not all uses of language outside
someone's culture are problematic quote
we live in a multilingual world where
we're always influencing one another's
language practices uh where we might
come into contact with a variety of
terms or language practices that we have
not grown up in says Nikki Lane cultural
and linguistic Anthropologist intention
matters most dropping hola or Shalom to
someone who you know speaks Spanish or
Hebrew for example isn't something to
worry about
actively Don a fake exaggerated accent
and say those words well therein lies
the problem
yeah but what if the fake accent is
hilarious
can we carve out an exception for
exaggerated accents that are
particularly funny
probably not continuing it says
uh quote like saying Nihao to someone
Asian American who isn't Chinese this
could be both othering and a
microaggression what we need is a
critical Consciousness in our public
around a language says Jeffrey McCune
director of the Frederick Douglass
Institute of African and African
American studies at the University of
Rochester language is too critical to
our culture that we can't just casually
use language in ways that might offend
and or even harm do harm to certain
groups of people it's the larger
cultural considerations around the use
of these words that matter most
quote I don't think the intention is
necessarily to be offensive or anything
but for native Hawaiian people Hawaiian
language was banned in schools after the
Hawaiian kingdom was overthrown Arvin
says considering how difficult it has
been to keep the language alive to see
someone using it without respect is
really difficult for that reason
ah so it's been difficult to keep the
Hawaiian language alive
which is why
you don't want people to use it
there was allegedly an effort to
eradicate the language and now parts of
the language are so common that even
people who are not Hawaiian use it and
that's a bad thing you say
well it's only bad when the word is used
without respect
but what sort of respect do we need to
Grant a word like Aloha what kind of
sacred reverence do you need to see
I'm not sure I know how to respect the
word Aloha even if I cared enough to try
which I don't whatever they mean by
respect the point is that our intentions
are what matters that's what they say
and on that point I actually agree
what matters most in any human
communication is intention
you cannot know how to respond to
someone or how to feel about what
they've said until you understand their
intention behind their words the meaning
they were trying to convey
the words and syllables themselves are
less functionally important in most
day-to-day communication than the
intended meaning behind them somebody
might phrase something incorrectly or
use a word in the wrong way but if you
know what they mean which most of the
time you do then the communication was
successful and only a tedious pedantic
jerk would feel the need to go back and
correct them the problem is that when
the left says intention is what matters
what they mean to say is
my perception of your intention is what
matters
they don't actually care about your
intention behind your own words
that can be less relevant to them
the words themselves are also basically
irrelevant they will just arbitrarily
decide what your motivations and
intentions were and they will adjust
their level of offense accordingly
but don't worry though they're not going
to leave you entirely in limbo wondering
what you should or shouldn't say and how
you should or shouldn't say it
they won't leave me in that limbo
because I simply don't care at all about
their language rules and I'm not waiting
for their permission to say anything but
if you are concerned about the rules and
uh and if you are determined to follow
them well our White Knight friend David
Oliver concludes his article with some
very helpful tips here they are quote
these action items will help keep keep
your language in check number one make
an effort to befriend people from other
cultures step outside your comfort zone
and talk to people who do not share our
values or our experiences says Sunni
Rucker Chang associate professor at the
center for Slavic East European and
Eurasian studies at the Ohio State
University
you'll likely get a better feel for
what's appropriate this way two ask
yourself why you are saying the term are
you using the term because you want to
say something besides hello or hey
consider the cultural implications
before you do McCune says is it to the
benefit of laughter and sarcasm and
satire or is it a genuine interest in
being a part of a cultural community
that recognizes the historical meaning
and historical significance of various
terms three remember the weight of words
quote language is really about power
says Rucker Chang and I think that the
person who is using these terms needs to
be more aware of the origins of them
four avoid terms you don't know once you
learn you might decide you you don't
want to use the term because you see
that it is indexing certain things that
have nothing to do with you and which
might reproduce ideas in which you are
not interested in reproducing
what okay five educate educate educate
whether it's history of colonialism in
Hawaii or other significant historical
facts knowledge helps fight ignorance
now one thing they don't cover is um
about what about when I when I
intentionally mispronounce foreign words
and foreign names simply because I find
it amusing to butcher terms I'm not
familiar with
like what about when I is that okay can
I do that
I guess it's not okay that's my guess
which only makes it more amusing to me
which ensures that I will continue doing
it even more as for the rest
um it's all nonsense of course consider
the cultural implications before saying
hello to someone
how is it even possible to function in
society if you have to treat every
conversation like some sort of Explorer
making contact with a primitive jungle
tribe for the first time paranoid that
one wrong move or phrase will result in
a spear through your chest and your
corpse roasting over you know an open
fire for dinner
of course it's not possible to function
that way which is part of the point
these people are very much opposed to
any functional vision of society or
human interaction function is what they
hate most of all and what in the hell
does she mean when she says language is
about power
I mean that's the kind of utterly
nonsensical statement that college
professors make to their students all
the time who are meant to just sit there
and mindlessly consume the nonsense like
baby birds inhaling whatever
half-digested muck is spewed at them
if you sit and think about it though for
for more than half a second you realize
that it makes no sense
and it makes no sense in the most
cynical and hideous way imaginable
because she is casting ordinary
communication
polite greetings between people as power
struggles
when you say hello to someone it's a
power struggle you are you are
exercising power over them by saying hi
she suggests that people ought to bring
their ancestral resentments and blood
feuds into every exchange seeing even a
statement like hello as an effort to
colonize and enslave them
as always then
we find that what appears to be merely
stupid on the surface turns out to be
still very stupid of course but even
more Insidious and hideous than it first
appeared
and this is ultimately why to David
Oliver and SUNY Rucker Chang and anyone
else associated with this article we
must say to all of them
Aloha and you're canceled
I'll do it for this portion of the shows
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]